for more than three months indian made
coded 19 vaccines have been delivered to
countries
around the world 60 million doses have
gone to 76 countries
as part of aid and commercial agreements
but
india recorded its highest number of
coronavirus cases in five
months this week and the government says
it must now prioritize
local supply the director general of the
world health organization says that's
understandable
but it's important india continues to
export vaccines
we're already in discussion to keep
a balance so that they can use
locally but at the same time continue
to provide other countries
vaccines from the serum institute of
india the crm institute of india which
is making the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
is the world's largest manufacturer and
the biggest contributor to the un-backed
kovacs alliance
india's decision to reduce exports is
already being felt overseas
we go and buy vaccines from a country
pay for it part of the shipment arrives
in the country
and when a second plane flies there
their attorney general blocks the
shipment
these are unpredictable things that we
face but there will be some relief in
india itself
health workers in maharashtra the worst
affected and second
most popular state are struggling to
deal with the highest number of cases
since the pandemic began
there are no beds available for them
here there's also a shortage of resident
doctors
even the resident doctors who are
available are overloaded with work
they aren't getting enough quarantine
days there is also a shortage of
supplies from the administration to an
extent
that is being resolved but it's not fast
enough because the number of patients is
so high
as cases rise the government has faced
criticism that it's exported
more doses than for the 58 million of
its own citizens
who have so far been inoculated the
government is running behind its
own schedule of vaccinating 300 million
people
by august to address that is expanding
the criteria for who's eligible for
vaccines
as it plans to scale up its inoculation
drive
elizabeth piranha al jazeera new delhi